Get ready for one of those big, "Oh, yeah!"
moments.
You know him as a robot on a bloody quest
for vengeance in a genre-defining show -- and
so much more.
Keep watching!
Disney has another big win on its hands with
Hawkeye, the most recent show in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe.
The series stars Hailee Steinfeld as future
Young Avenger Kate Bishop, a maverick archer
who joins up with Clint Barton to take down
the Tracksuit Mafia and their leader, Echo.
Also known as Maya Lopez, Echo is depicted
as a deaf antagonist looking to avenge the
death of her father, who Clint killed during
his time as vigilante Ronin.
Part of Hawkeye's third episode tells Maya's
origin story, detailing the events of her
early life.
This plotline also introduces her father,
William Lopez, and the reason for Maya's dogged
pursuit of Clint and Kate.
"You have to learn to jump between two worlds."
Though William's time on Hawkeye is fleeting,
viewers may just recognize the actor who plays
him.
Zahn McClarnon has had roles in movies and
television since the late '80s, but one of
his most recognizable parts is that of Officer
Mathias on Longmire.
This series is a modern Western that follows
Sheriff Longmire and his attempt to solve
crimes in Wyoming after the death of his wife.
A&E canceled after only three seasons but
was picked up by Netflix, though it was eventually
canned after three more seasons.
McClarnon's Officer Mathias appeared as a
foil to Longmire on the show.
As the chief of police for the Cheyenne reservation,
Mathias' professional interests are often
at odds with Longmire.
As an Indigenous actor, McClarnon's casting
gave a relevance to the series that depicted
the lives of Native people.
Not long after he exited Longmire, McClarnon
joined the cast of Westworld, beginning with
the Season 2 episode, "Reunion."
This HBO series is an update of the 1973 film
of the same name, in which robots at a futuristic
theme park gain sentience and overthrow their
oppressors.
In Season 2 of Westworld, Dolores becomes
the leader of the robot resistance.
However, this narrative encounters a somewhat
confusing plot twist when Native American
robot Akecheta enters the show.
Akecheta is the leader of the Ghost Nation,
having been created to act as a villain for
a violent narrative in the park.
As it turns out, Akecheta actually became
self-aware years before Dolores and the other
hosts.
McClarnon's portrayal as the Westworld Host
is incredibly nuanced, and he gives an amazing
and heartfelt performance in the role.
As Akecheta, he struggles with his consciousness,
determined to lead his compatriots into a
new world.
Soon after Westworld, Zahn McClarnon featured
in the 2019 horror movie Doctor Sleep.
In this adaptation of the Stephen King novel,
McClarnon depicts a villainous character named
Crow Daddy.
Both he and the film's lead antagonist Rose
the Hat encounter Danny Torrance as they attempt
to hunt down a powerful young girl named Abra,
in the hopes of feeding on her ability to
"shine."
Rose the Hat, Crow Daddy, and the rest of
their cult are established as antagonists
with no redeeming qualities.
They survive only off of the death of innocents
and, as a result, suffer the consequences
at the hands of Danny and Abra.
Crow Daddy obviously doesn't live to see the
end of the film, but McClarnon nevertheless
used the role to prove that he can play one
heck of a villain.
In Zahn McClarnon's most recent television
credit before Hawkeye, the actor demonstrated
his comedic chops on the FX series Reservation
Dogs.
Created by Taika Waititi, the show is a candid
depiction of teenagers living on a reservation
in present-day Oklahoma.
Over the course of the show's first season,
viewers follow four kids who dream of escaping
the confines of the reservation, committing
petty crimes to fund their eventual getaway.
McClarnon appears in four episodes of the
show's first season as Big, a noble, but sometimes
oblivious, reservation police officer.
The actor doesn't often get to play to the
funnier side of things during his roles, but
his character here is a welcome source of
levity on a show that, at times, can actually
be kinda bleak.
Thankfully, Reservation Dogs has been renewed
for a Season 2 — so McClarnon is likely
to reprise his role sometime in the near future.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.